das ist beatee und das ist ihr unfassbar
schöner Gemüsegarten in den Schweizer
Alpen als Bär die Idee hatte ihr eigenes
Gemüse anzubauen hat sie oft gehört an
dem steellen hangrundstück der ganze
Garten ist doch sowieso voller Bauschutt
da ist überhaupt keine Gartenerde mehr
übrig und in den Schweizer Alpen auf der
Höhe wächst doch sowieso nichts zum
Glück hat sie trotzdem ihr Ding
durchgezogen und diesen unglaublichen
Gemüsegarten angelegt bea ist
Teilnehmerin in meinem Onlinekurs Gemüse
Garten starten und deswegen durften wir
sie besuchen und diese wunderschöne
Gartentour für euch Filmen der Garten
ist der Hammer ist so schön viele Leute
glauben dass sie an so einem
hangrundstück einfach gar keine Chance
haben bete anzulegen halt wahrscheinlich
sehr viel Arbeit gewesen aber guck mal
wie sich das auszeaht wir sind jetzt
seit 5 Jahren hier und jetzt ist so sage
ich jetzt mal das zweite das dritte Jahr
wo der Garten eigentlich so ist wo ich
sage der ist perfekt so wie ich es
möchte Gärten sind schattig manchmal ist
der Boden voller Steine und mal wachsen
da wo man eigentlich Bee anlegen will
lauter prommenbeeren oder der Garten
liegt an demem steilen Hang wie bei Bea
und Bea ist wie ich finde das perfekte
Beispiel dafür dass so gut wie kein
Garten von Anfang an perfekt ist und
dass man trotzdem das Beste aus dem
machen kann was man bei sich zu Hause
vorfindet stellt euch mal vor Bea hätte
einfach den Kopf in den Sand gesteckt
und dieser wunderschöne Garten wä nie
entstanden aber das ist ist auch nicht
von heute auf morgen kommen wir haben
uns erstmal überlegt okay was können wir
machen dann haben wir mit dem Backer
erstmal den Hang terrassiert wir haben
alle Sträucher und Bäume gefällt damit
überhaupt erstmal der ganze bauchschutz
zum Vorschein kam und dann haben wir
erstmal Gründung auf die Ebenen gemacht
ja das wirklich auch erstmal den Boden
aufgebaut und das dauert auch ein zwei
Jahre und dann haben wir hier den
sellery für den Winter weil wir müssen
ja gucken im Winter steht bei uns die
Sonne nicht so hoch und das sind die
bete die am ersten Sonne haben und auch
noch am letzten und wo ich auch noch am
besten hinkommen wenn wir anderthalb
oder vielleicht 2 m Schnee haben muss
ich mir mit der Schaufel ja in den
Garten schlagen oder weil sie erntet das
ganze Jahr über genau 1000 m ich habe
den Winterkurs gemacht und habe
festgestellt ich muss gar nichts machen
ich pack die nicht mal mit dem flie ein
Marine ich packe die wirklich nur
rasenverschnitt Hackschnitzel und dann
ganz ganz ganz viel Laub und das gute
ist ja wirklich wenn es geschneit hat
dann ist es super isoliert ja ist das
über die Jahre hin Ei einfach gewachsen
dass wir gesagt wenn wir machen die
Terrassierung und wir machen den
Schneckenzaun wie man ihn hier sieht wir
buddeln ihn nicht ein sondern wir setzen
ihn oben drauf weil wir müssen ganz ganz
viel Kombos und guten Mist einfach oben
aufbringen weil wir müssen mit diesem
bauchchutt Leben den wir hier haben wir
können nicht das ganze Grundstück
abtragen sondern müssen einfach
versuchen jetzt ein gutes Ökosystem ein
gutes Boden Lebewesen hier
reinzubekommen und das haben wir über
die Jahre immer wieder geschafft indem
wir aber auch sehr viel im Herbst
wirklich die beE vollhen mit
rasenverschnitt mit Hackschnitzel mit
kumus mit mit Blättern mit Laub mit
allem kriegen so eine richtige
welleniskur und im Frühjahr ist das
alles weg ist das aufgemamft und
mittlerweile kann man wirklich ein
spartenstich machen und man hat 1 m
Tiefe und der Bauschutt ist der ist zwar
noch da aber die Bodenqualität hat
einfach wahnsinnig
zugenommen und ich glaube das ist auch
was viele denken ich kann auf meinem
Grundstück mit meinem Boden weil habe
gar nicht arbeiten doch kannst du fang
einfach mal langsam an auch auch auf
bauschot geht geht zu gärtnern ihr
seht's Gemüsegarten starten ist mein
Onlinekurs mit dem ich euch durchs ganze
Garten begleite und indem ich euch mein
dreiphasen gartensystem zeige das ist
ein System nachdem auch be gärtnet das
darauf ausgelegt ist bei möglichst wenig
Arbeit möglichst viel ernten zu können
und dabei mit der Natur zu arbeiten
statt gegen die Natur und diese Woche
läuft zum Start in die neue Gartensaison
eine Rabattaktion wo ihr 100 € auf den
Kurspreis spart also wenn ihr mit dabei
sein wollt dann findet ihr den Link im
obersten angepinnten Kommentar hier sind
meine Kartoffeln
für Käfig hier das ist auch gegen Sturm
wir haben hier manchmal 120 180 da
hinten ist das cend ist da haben wir
2500 m also wir sind ja schon ein
bisschen rauer und die Kartoffeln sind
ja sehr sensibel und brechen ja relativ
schnell und hier ist einfach so die
windfront und weil die wirklich jedes
Jahr so hoch und so gut wer haben wir
gesagt ja gut mein man ist im Tiefbau
bisschen armierungsgitter in die Höhe
geht auch und dann bauen wir da immer so
ein kleinen Käfig damit die wenn die
sage ich jetzt mal brechen dann wir
mindestens noch ein bisschen
und uns nicht kaputt gehen und damit man
natürlich auch noch zwischen den beden
ein bisschen lang kommt und da muss man
auch wirklich sagen man muss einfach
natürlich mit dem Wetter gehen oder wenn
im März alle in der Gruppe anfangen zu
schreien juhu ich gehe raus in den
Garten da trinke ich noch ein Tee und
denk so schön der Schnee kommt im Mai
noch mal lassen wir mal noch ein
bisschen warten aber dafür haben wir das
Gewächshaus dafür kann man vorziehen
oder man kann auch einfach nachher im
Baumarkt oder eben auf dem
regionalenmarkt Setzlinge kaufen oder
ich muss nicht alles selber machen oder
also stresst euch nicht ich habe in den
ersten Z D Jahren auch keine Setzlinge
vorgezogen sondern ich habe auch einfach
erstmal geguckt wo kann ich mir Arbeit
sparen und was macht mir Freude und dann
wächst man mit den Jahren und jetzt
ziehen wir die eigenen Setzlinge weil
ich einfach weiß ich kriege im August
oder ich kriege im Juli einfach nicht
mehr das Gemüse an Setzlingen was ich
möchte und dann wird man kreativ und
dann kann man sein eigenes Saat gut
ziehen und dann kommt man da so rein
Schritt für Schritt aber nicht alles auf
einmal wollen man darf einfach den Spaß
an der Freude nicht vergessen und ich
glaube das ist ganz ganz
wichtig
früher war hier ganz viel Hecke und dann
haben wir uns ein häckler gekauft und
jetzt tut mein Mann immer das ganze
Hackschnitzel hier runter häxeln und
wenn er Rasen mäht da oben lieg da kommt
der neue rasenvchnitter runter und dann
nehme ich mir meine hake und misch mir
mein eigenes Mulch gleich der erste
Regenwurm hallo ja hier ist alles voll
hier ist alles voller Regenwürmer
Kellerasseln also der Boden lebt ne
Engerlinge das ist hier und das wit ig
ist man denkt ja immer die Hackschnitzel
sind dann nächst jah noch da das ist
alles im Frühjahr wie weg ich frage mich
immer wo ist das hin alles aufgegessen
also so viel Material wie wir immer auf
den beten aufbringen das ist Wahnsinn
und im Frühjahr sind die bete wieder wie
flach und wir machen wieder neuen Mist
und komus vom Nachbarn rauf und alles
weggefressen
ja ich bin nicht so der lesewurm bin ich
ganz ehrlich sondern ich gucke lieber
mal ein Video und ich bin wahnsinnig
guter autodidaktor und dann bin ich
irgendwie auf deine Kurse gekommen und
da fand ich das praktisch da ist
wirklich alles schon zusammen du musst
nicht noch gucken welche Pflanze
vertrreht sich mit dem was ist mit dem
Boden sondern es ist eigentlich das
ganze wissen was du dir vielleicht aus
zich verschiedenen grosen und Büchern
zusammenholen müsstest ist einfach
konfakt und du nimmst das bucklet und
guckst gut die Pflanze braucht den und
den Nährstoff den und den Partner und
das hilft ungemein du hast alles
eigentlich was du brauchst auf einen
Schlag also es wird auch vieles
drumherum noch mitbearbeitet wo ich sage
interessiert mich auch noch super mach
haltbar chellen z.B ist auch eine ganz
tolle Sache oder we klar wenn man den
Garten hat wo soll das Zeug denn hin ich
kann das nicht alles auf einmal essen
und am Ende sage ich jetzt mal ist das
alles wie so ein roter Faden wo du mit
dem KO anfängst und eigentlich mit jedem
ko weitermachen kannst von der Marie
weil die bauen alle so schön aufeinander
auf und das ganze wisschen hilft dir
also es ist immer wieder eine
Bereicherung es gab B jetzt noch nichts
wo ich gesagt habe das kann ich jetzt
gar nicht gebrauchen oder gar nicht
umsetzen ne also ist schon eine super
Lebenshilfe sage ich jetzt mal der AL
hat ein hammerose
blütens und ein Brownie und ein ja und
ein
Kräutertee komme ja aus der ehemaligen
DDR bei uns ist natürlich Stachelbeeren
das muss sein Stachelbeer bekuchen und
Himbeeren und da haben wir hier zwei
himbeersorten und hier ja die Brombeeren
kommen von ganz alleine also das ist
jetzt nicht so eine süße
Sorte aber ist trotzdem
lecker und das gute ist auch hier ist
der Tiefbau meines Manns wieder ganz
praktisch ich tue nämlich mit dem
markierungsspray wir unten den Ast
ansprühen in der Farbe der getragen hat
damit ich weiß welche ich im Herbst
rückschneiden muss damit ich mir ja
nicht die guten Triebe wo es nächst J
dran trägt zurückschneide
[Musik]
schlau also das ist natürlich das Gute
oder wenn du dir morgens der Müsli im
Garten zusammenstellst ne und du gehst
rum und denkst ich noch ein
bisschen noch ein bisschen himbe noch
ein paar stachelbeären dann haben wir
hier unsere weißen maulbär der
maulbeärbaum ist eigentlich ein ganz
ganz alter schweizerbaum der war früher
als Futter für die Seidenraupen auch
bekannt und weiße Maul wden können bis
zu -30° ab und relativ viel viel Wind
die sind schnellwüchsig der ist erst 3
Jahre alt also wer sich wirklich
Maulbeerbaum holen will kann ich weiß
empfehlen die blauen maulberären kennt
man ja die sind eher so ein bisschen
bitter und die sind wirklich sehr sehr
süß die sind so gut wir haben auch so
einen in unserem alten Garten das ist
wie Zucker kennst du den sternppi das
ist ein Apfel warum der schon zu
Römerzeiten bekannt war und zwar macht
ja keine runden Äpfel sondern die sehen
so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Trapez
also wie so ein Stern und wenn du die so
aufschneidest und apfelschips machst
dann sieht es aus wie so ein Querschnitt
von so
so toll vor allem euer Garten ist nicht
besonders groß ne du kannst du kannst
mit so wenig so viel machen eigentlich
oder
[Musik]
ja das ist der
Hammer ich glaube jetzt ist es
eigentlich mehr ein Gewächshaus also für
die zweibeinigen Gewächse geworden weil
wir haben gesagt also okay die Tomaten
die und die Paprikas die kommen auch
wunderbar in den den Töpfen guckt euch
das an was da für klle große Paprika
sind dicke Paprika da dran hängen ich
habe ja viele Jahre in Spanien gelebt
und so ein bisschen so die Südfrüchte
fehen mir und das schöne ist ja die
Feigen wir hatten jetzt schon immer
schön im Müsli Feigen gehabt und jetzt
sie wieder voller Früchte und kommt hier
auch wunderbar in den Schweizer Alben
Feigen wer hat das schon wer hat das
schon ne das kann ich jeder
[Musik]
genau also es ist natürlich schon so wir
sind h in der tiefsten Schweiz im
abenzeller Land oder dann kommt eine
düsche und meint wir gerdenn hier auf
1000 m wo andere in den letzten 20 30
Jahren gesagt haben na ja weiß ich nicht
ist ganz schön rau wenn du meinst
versuch mal mittlerweile ist es aber
wirklich so dass wir hier auch
verschiedene andere Gärtnerinnen haben
die Permakultur machen die den Leuten
das Wissen weitergeben und von dem wir
gegenseitig profitieren können aber es
gibt immer noch so die standardleute die
sagen wirklich das wächst hier oh das
ist ja toll wie du hast im Winter noch
Gemüse kann ich mal gucken die beiden
haben ihr Gewächshaus in eine kleine
Wohlfühloase verwandelt und einfach ein
Bett und ein Sofa reingestellt und be
hat vorgeschlagen dass ich heute im
Gewächshaus übernachte hört ihr den
Regen auf dem Dach es ist so schön hier
wir dachten wir kommen für einen
wunderschönen gemüsegartener weil dieser
Garten ist einfach noch so viel mehr das
ist wirklich ein erweitertes
Wohnzimmer also man muss auch dem Gemüse
viel viel mehr zutrauen oder natürlich
muss ich hier im Winter einfach ein
bisschen mehr machen muss einfach die
Sachen schön einpacken aber wenn ich im
Winter bei -20° rausgehe muss ich mir
auch schön einpacken und genauso ist es
mit dem Gemüse und wenn es geschneit hat
dann ist es ja schön warm eingepackt und
wenn dann die minusrade kommen ist es
egal das ist so unser grünkohlbeet hier
h noch mehr Zwiebeln davon habt ihr echt
jede Menge ne Zwiebeln haben wir relativ
viel wen wir sehr sehr gerne Zwiebeln
essen und ich muss sagen letztes jah
hat's gerade so gereicht und dies jah
müssen wir einfach mal schauen wenn man
sagt immer Bau noch mehr Zwiebeln an wir
sind hier auf 1000 m im Winter ich habe
gar nicht die Möglichkeit unten an meine
bete zu kommen und bei den hochbeten
habe ich die Möglichkeit auch wie bei
hier da haben wir so ein Gestell oben
drauf gemacht dass wir die im Winter
einfach wunderbar mit einem folietunnel
drüber ziehen und dann kann ich die
ganzen fünf hochbilder eigentlich im
Winter nutzen denn wenn es schneit tue
ich einfach nur den Schnee oben runter
und kann trotzdem unter die Folie hier
haben wir die Karotte blühen lassen ich
lasse immer gerne und ziehe auch gerne
mein eigenes Saatgut und das ist jetzt
die kniff die rote Karotte oder die
sieht auch mega lecker aus im Salat und
wenn die blüht das ist so schön auch
immer noch mal zwischen und die frühers
sage ich jetzt mal Blüher bringen ja
nicht viel für die Bienen hier oben und
dann ist das immer auch noch mal schön
und natürlich auch der schweibens z oder
der schweibenschwanzschmetterling den es
bei uns sehr viel gibt der liebt
natürlich karottedill oder Fenchel und
am Anfang des Jahres gibt's noch gar
nicht so viel und die ist jetzt vom
September wenn man mal sieht was kann
eigentlich die Pflanze noch oder also
die wenigsten kommen drauf ich habe auch
öfter Kinder hier und die wenigsten
kommen noch fr mal was ist denn das das
ist echt erstaunlich auch mal ein
Radieschen blühen zu lassen das ist eine
ganz andere Erscheinung auf
einmal Beate Gärtner hat auf 56 quadr
betetfläche das ist relativ wenig und
trotzdem erntet sie so viel dass sie die
Nachbarn gleich mitversorgt ich hatte
letztes Jahr noch drei Familien
miternährt mit einer Gemüsekiste der
unischer Gemüsekiste und habe dies hier
auf zwei reduziert du bist schon richtig
stolz
oder so so krass und das muss so viel
Arbeit gewesen sein das erstmal zu
terrassieren und an den Punkt zu kommen
wo ihr jetzt seid du musst nicht alles
sofort und auf einmal machen du es muss
ja noch Spaß machen oder und wenn du dir
selber und wenn du dir selber nachher zu
viel Druck und zu viel Stress machst
oder dann kannst das nicht genießen du
musst auch zwischendurch mal mit dem
Kaffee im Garten sitzen und denken oh
ist das schön und was hab ich alles
schon geschafft oder einfach mal auch
mit dem glücklich sein ne was man alles
schon erreicht hat und sich nicht immer
mit anderen vergleichen natürlich gibt
1us andere Gärten die sind schöner die
sind besser die sind schneller muss dich
auch mal fragen was willst du ne ist es
das was du willst oder wie gesagt das
ist hier kein Job sondern das soll eine
freiz das soll dich ja glücklich machen
das soll ja der aus g sein zum Alltag
oder wenn Ihr auch Lust habt in
Gemüsegarten starten mit dabei zu sein
und euren Gemüsegarten dieses Jahr
komplett zu transformieren dann findet
ihr den Link im obersten angepindnten
Kommentar ansonsten geht raus und macht
die Welt ein bisschen grüner und wir
sehen uns im nächsten Video wieder
macht's gut tschüss danke dass wir bei
dir sein können ja gerne gerne so
unglaublich